[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the
bucharest granchester stage here we are
in the building of the romanian
parliament we are very excited to see
the opening ceremony and the drawing of
lots to learn who will be playing in the
first round let's go for it
[Music]
it's a great ceremony it's really a
beautiful place and it's quite rare that
you're you know in a parliament for an
opening ceremony wow that was my
experience i mean beautiful environment
especially for chess i've never
i i don't recall being into the
parliament of my own country actually so
you know being uh being here is really
spectacular
i'm very pleased to be here in
in bucharest so where it's you know it's
the
chess
modern adventure of the game of just
eastern europe has started
[Music]
yeah really looking forward to the
tournament once you get the parents you
know
your opponent for the first round
immediately you start thinking what
you're going to play but yeah it was
really great the opening ceremony
it's been an amazing opening ceremony we
saw the drawing of lots we saw the
simultaneous exhibition and now let's
come back to the exciting games